you guys probably aren't familiar can
you explain any of these characters to
Tomiko B um I do a belligerent teenage
character a belligerent old age lady an
old-age pensioner character that I think
all my characters quite belligerent we
realized was writing this one it's the
one thing they will have in common it's
they tend not to like the world so it's
just it's just lots of different
characters yeah
and lands voice cuz there's an old
granny I've had a foul-mouthed granny
but like properly foul-mouthed you do
something else all right
Oh actually yeah I got the voice when I
was at drama school when I was training
and they split up a year and half the
year went to two schools to give kids a
really serious devised play about not
taking drugs the other well the other
half except for four of us went to
another school to talk about using
condoms when you start having sex great
four of us got asked to go around the
local Aldi old-age pensioners homes and
give them a trip down memory lane which
as it turns out old people can't be
dragged down memory lane I don't want to
go so we turned up you know it was about
18 and they put us in sort of old AG
clothes and hats and they asked and we
used to go in to their recreation rooms
yeah there's a table tennis yeah create
for their sort of recreation room and
we'd stand up in front of them and sing
I think it was the Andrew sisters or
something they go well we'd have to go
dancing under the apple tree with anyone
else but me and as we walked on there
was one place it was in Temple for
chinks I went to central North London
and they sent us this lace and I walked
on one lady as I walked on she went oh
here we go
and I listen extraordinary and as I was
doing my stuff and we were we did it for
about 20 minutes and all the time she
was just like well she sholde I know
you're gonna and at the end of it we've
been doing very professional job as we
are 18 you know whatever it was you
knows it's a long way to tipperary
Johnny and at the end of it she went is
she gonna stay on your front about
packing jelly all day
[Applause]
[Music]